来这个圆领开张大吉
开张快乐
使我开心
来这个圆领的这个T
这个卫衣啊
胸围胸围
104 110
104可以拉伸到110
长度49
来这款也是给大家的福利价
19扣2
这个好像有四个色
四个色
有黑的
有灰的
有这个颜色
好像还有个咔的
来谁要谁来扣
19扣2啊
面料嘎嘎好
这个短一点的
其实我喜欢像短的
但是领子这种
我穿着了会显胖
穿着这领子
我应该会显胖
来这一款来给宝贝看一下
牛仔裤
威拉威拉
来S吗
我那天穿的那个裤子
是哪个小姐姐要的
忘记了
来这个腰式松紧
我自留的那个裤子
找到了一条
不知道是哪个小姐姐要的了
腰为64
可以拉到84
臀为104
可以拉伸到108
当长是35
裤长是102
来这一款
咱们谁要谁来扣39
扣个3
谁要谁来扣个3
喜欢的姐姐就扣39
扣3
扣个3
今天拉过来一大车子
来这个直腾裤裤子
衣服裙子啥都有啊
来这个裤子灰色的
灰色的这个
我说实话夏天穿可能有点热
这个要春秋穿啊
腰式半腰松紧的灰色直腾裤
腰式半腰松紧
两边有袭拉口袋
屁股后面是一个光满光满啊
来这一款咱们来量一下
腰为66
可以拉伸到86
腿为66
腿为106
可以拉伸到110
来当场是38
裤长的话是100
来这种裤子谁要39
扣个1
39谁要谁来扣个1
来喜欢的姐姐一锅
39扣1
来这个地球音乐家的这个裙
我看这个是有问题的不
这个是这个是有问题的
有扣有位啊
这个这个他砸的看看
这后面砸的这里有点掉掉
有点掉在这里啊
要要回去要修一下
那这个的话我给大家放福利吧
好吧
面料去纸的这个长卷
袖子是个松紧袖
前面有一排扣
前面有一排扣子啊
来这一款咱们来量一下
已经啊面料去纸
胸围的话是96
98腰围的话是80828082
群长的话是120啊
来这个裙子谁要9块9块9块扣0扣0
来喜欢的姐姐一锅9块扣个0啊
这个原来都是59的
那后面那里到采访那里就搞一下就行了
9块9块扣0扣0来喜欢的姐姐一锅拉
9块9块扣0扣0
来这个细条纹的这个裤子腰上是松紧
腰有出绳
两边骨的这个应该是棉的
摸着面料好软啊薄的
棉一百看
棉一百
但这个是两个L的
两个L的
但腰上有抽绳
两边两边有口袋
看到了吗细条纹啊细条纹
哇这个我说实话啊
咱们外穿也行
在家穿也行
面料嘎嘎舒服
来腰围哎不不大等
两个L的腰围66
可以拉伸到100
臀围114.5mm
可以拉伸到116
114 116
当长是35
当长35
扣长100
来这个裤子谁要29
29扣个2
还给你们便宜了
薄的溜薄溜薄的啊
棉一百
棉一百的
来这个裤子谁要谁来扣
29谁要谁来扣个2
面料很舒服的啊
谁要谁来扣
29扣个2
29谁要谁来扣个2
来这个橘色的这个裤子
两边裤脚两边开叉
腰是松紧腰
腰上有出绳
裤脚两边开叉的啊
腰是松紧腰
腰上有出绳
这个亮色亮色啊
两边有口袋
腰围66
可以拉伸到82
臀围100
可以拉伸到106
当长33
裤长94
来这个裤子咱们有姐姐喜欢的话来
扣2扣2
来喜欢的姐姐就扣了
谁要谁来扣个2
来走过路过不要错过了啊
来这个是个格子的
牌子是这个牌子
全棉
全棉全棉这个牌子9码啊
是一个9码棉100
棉100棉100的啊
来领子后面是有有扣有扣牙的
领扣后面是有扣有扣牙的全棉的
这个格子裙
姐姐刚刚那个裤子男生能穿不
你看一下裤长够不够
如果他瘦的话是可以穿的
说实话这种裤子不挑男女
啊不挑男生女生的
他裤长够不够
裤长够的话就可以
因为他前面没有这个棉巾
啊不分男生女生的
这个是全棉的可好了
这个说实话应该贵一点
98的裤长可以吗
如果可以的话我跟你说穿着可舒服了
全棉的
棉100
所以我放旁边了
像这种全棉的可以啊ok
谢谢你
来
你要不也要穿全棉的啊
你要不要口罩
全棉的口罩你要不再送你一个
给力
全棉的口罩也是日单的
咱们原来是993个的
我给你拿一个啊
来381381谢谢
太给力了怎么那么给力呢
太给力了
拿个全棉的口罩送你
三百一千
原来是
g
我们 circulation
我给你拿去了问
我这里有点别人
自己自己
哎呀哎呀哎呀哎呀啊
我多拿几个
上次还有个小姐姐
她说姐姐能再给我个口罩吗
我妈妈喜欢
啊这个是全年的
全年的
你帮我问一下米
啊薄薄荷绿那个条纹长袖
嗯还有一个老好卖
还有一个老好卖
找客服还不快点
啊薄荷绿的那个条纹长袖
问一下米
是哪啥时候过的
啥时候过的亲爱的
呃客服就是他老公
你去找他去
264我拍了没找到
那我等一会再给你找找
来381321号谢谢
谢谢无关心动谢谢
等一下我再去给你找一家苹果气泡
来这个全年的这个裙格子裙啊
年100年100的
领口后面也会有个眼的来
胸围的话是104108104108
来腰围和胸围一样的啊
来裙长102裙子长度102
来这个裙子谁要谁来勾39
39扣个3姐妹们啊
来谁要谁来勾格子的这个裙
39扣3全民全民好大
苹果气泡这个超级好
面料嘎嘎好
谢谢
也给你送个口罩
也给小瓶呃小苹果苹果气泡来
321好截图你先截个图再给你量一下
好
裙长的话是103104
一长103104
103104看到膝盖下面
到膝盖下面
看到了不
这个老好了
这种按理说应该都是要59的
我所以都给你们有的时候
没有写价格的
我们都给你们放福利了
姐妹们啊
都给你们放福利了
这个老好了
哎送个口罩
送个口罩
这几个口罩
给他送完
送完
是264是吧
是264是不是苹果
苹果气泡
等一下我给你找找去
来这个是ioma
圆领圆领
来
这个小熊的这个头圆领圆领
来这一款好的264我记着了
来这一款哎我把面料锯纸啊
胸围108可以拉伸到112
长度的话是68
来这款谁要9块9块
扣1扣1
9块扣个1来这个小熊的这个梯啊
9块9块啊
谁要谁来扣个1
谁要谁来扣个1啊
来吧
哎我那天穿那个牛仔裤
我自留那个是哪个小姐姐要的
这有个威朗
中高腰的
中高腰的啊
这种裤型穿出来都是很好看的
很显瘦
有裤有裤呀两边口袋
屁股后面有口袋
前面底边开个叉
这种含棉量都挺高的
看棉70聚酯28
聚胺酯2%
啊麻烦姐问一下你是不是
麻烦姐问一下你是不是
放在今天发的包裹里发抖了
好的
马上给他发个信息
薄荷绿条纹的长袖
明明明明
那个苹果气泡的那一个
啊塔雷斯哥264
你今天有没有给他放
薄荷里面发抖
那你还没找着呢
来腰围的话是66
可以拉到80
腿尾的话是100
可以拉升到106
刚刚那个小姐姐要问的是啥
当场32
当场32裤长101
来春秋的有藏青米色薄荷绿
那个
啊我知道了知道了你是少哪个颜色
来这一款谁要2929扣个2
29啊这个
这个威喇的这个牛仔裤中高要的29扣个2
29abil 弓竿
29谁要谁 copy  resonates
29谁要谁来扣个二
谁要谁来送个二
我和绿的抽丝的那一条
264是吗
264我再给你看一下
我再跟你看一下看有没有
没有的话等她她回我信息
響鐘
这里是没有
那个框里面
我都给你扒拉出来了
没有
等他回我
我知道是哪个了
这一款对不对
上次在我手上买的
给你19的
这个款对吧
这个款的绿色对不对
这款的绿色
没看到
这里没看到
来这一个全棉的
这个格子会丢吗
我好喜欢
没事丢的话
我再给你找一个
应该不会
要么他就发到别人那里了
要么他就给你放到
那个今天的货里面了
等他回我
还没回我呢
估计在睡觉
来这个全棉
全棉的这个格子衬衫
前面有一排扣
有扣有扣
前面短后面长
前面短一点
后面长一点
来这个格子的这个衬衫
来
胸围胸围
130 132
来长度前面71
后面81
来这个原价69的
现在39
39扣个5
原来是69的全棉的
39 39扣个5
这个衬衫
非常好穿
全棉
全棉全棉
我侄女也好喜欢
上一条就是被他拿走了
我再又扣一条
没事没事
如果没有了
我再给你找
那个还有的
那个应该还能找到
圆领圆领的这个毛衣
短的看
短的
来这个毛衣
近距离给你们看一下